ah look at this Robin look who's here my  family my guest announcer Marianne from  Brooklyn take it away honey  [Music]  it's always wrong you how attractive she  no it's not nice I am here to represent  all the fans I gotta say Laurieann  really is the biggest fan  [Applause]  so calm down calm down does it hurt your  throat when you yell like you are a doll  okay your guests that save some energy  for your announcements later all right  where was Maryann when I was in college  and I needed to get where were you  Oh your big real quick Mary we're on a  schedule takers with a big show but I  must say Anne Murray from Queens is on  it's freaking out that you're here  [Music]  [Music]  what do you think of that in  [Applause]  [Music]  [Laughter]  [Applause]  [Applause]  she is here live Ann Marie it's like  it's like if you took dental drills and  made them duel that's what I'm hearing  right now